even if you are without symptoms you are
encroaching on their individual rights
because you're making them vulnerable
fear wants to protect you from
everything including yourself okay this
means masking forever
there's no limiting principle at all so
all of this has to do with
a a public health rethinking of the way
we all ought to live
our life and this was stated nowhere
better over the weekend than dr anthony
fauci the great
and sainted he who guards saint peter's
pearly gates dr anthony fauci the
greatest doctor
in all of human history never
flip-flopped on a single issue except
for every single issue
has held more positions on every single
issue in the pandemic than the kama
sutra does with regard to sexual
positions
here is dr anthony fauci now explaining
that
you need to mask up and the reason you
need a mask up even if you're vaccinated
is because let's say that you're
vaccinated and let's say everyone around
you
has had the opportunity to get
vaccinated you are encroaching on
someone else's right
not to get sick um
i wasn't aware that someone else has a
right
not to get sick i who guarantees this
should we all lock ourselves in our
homes to prevent this from happening
and what what is somebody else's right
not to get sick especially from people
who don't know if they have the virus
we're not talking about somebody who's
out there
coughing and spitting we're talking
about somebody who for all
intents and purposes is not sick you
have a right not to be sick from them
says dr anthony fauci
um interesting interesting here we go
a person's individual individual
decision to not wear a mask not only
impacts them
because if they get infected even though
they say it's my decision
if i get infected i'll worry about that
but the fact is if you get infected
even if you are without symptoms you
very well may infect
another person who may be vulnerable who
may get seriously ill
so in essence you are encroaching on
their individual rights
because you're making them vulnerable
okay so here's the thing there may have
been a certain logic to this particular
position last year
when there was no vaccine when there was
no way to protect yourself once n95s
were widely available this stopped being
the case
once n95s which are very productive
apparently against transmission of the
virus once those were available
if you really want to be protected you
were 95.
okay put that aside forget about the
masking for a second
now everyone in the united states had
the opportunity to get a vaccine in fact
the vast majority of people who are
seriously vulnerable
have gotten the vaccine meaning everyone
above the age of 65 90 of all americans
above the age of 65 have gotten the
vaccine he is now suggesting that i
the vaccinated person right who did my
due diligence
did my duty got the vaccine that it is
now my responsibility
even if i am completely asymptomatic to
wear a mask
because you have a right not to be sick
okay this means masking forever there's
no limiting principle at all
at all because it turns out that people
are constantly getting sick from each
other my kids
in a normal circumstance are constantly
coming home with a cold they're
constantly coming home sick with
something
this is what it means to be a child
right basically classrooms are giant
petri dishes of kids getting each other
sick
do my kids have a right to be free of
illness
when people don't know they are
transmitting it i'm unaware of this
right
but once you establish this right there
has to be a gatekeeper and who is that
gatekeeper
who would own the power to tell you what
to do on a daily basis
why wouldn't it be anthony fauci
wouldn't it be rochelle
wolenski wouldn't it be all of these
people now the media have glommed onto
this with alacrity and it's been fun to
watch
members of the white house angry at the
media for up-playing the threat of the
virus
this has been happening a lot so for
example the new york times had a
headline last week that is just
inaccurate
right it's just alarmist crap the
headline was cdc internal report calls
delta variants as contagious
as chickenpox okay but that really
wasn't the headline that they put on
twitter the headline they put out on
twitter
was breaking news the delta variant is
as contagious as chickenpox
and may be spread by vaccinated people
as easily as the unvaccinated an
internal cdc report said
okay that's just misinformation that is
not true
the reason it is not true is because
vaccinated people
are infected far less often than people
who are unvaccinated
so the new york times just puts out a
false tweet okay this actually led
members of the
biden administration to yell at the new
york times i've noticed that tweet has
not been taken down
that tweet is still up over at twitter
they've not been in any way cracked down
on
for misinformation however sky australia
was taken completely they were suspended
from youtube
they were suspended from youtube
supposedly for promulgating
misinformation
what exactly was the misinformation they
suggested that masked mandates and
lockdowns in australia
have not been a successful strategy and
youtube took them down
so the way this works is that if you are
super duper alarmist
in your misinformation then it gets to
stay up
if however you are not alarmist in your
actual correct information you may get
taken down
anyway how's this for a title ben
shapiro show subscriber destroys like
button with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang